[Music]
you know i was thinking about this song
i heard on the radio the other day sam
this scene is one of the most powerful
scenes in our film
how many roads must
walk down before you call
him a man the bob dylan blowing in the
wind
was a nagging thing to him because he
did feel like i should have written that
song i just
love those lyrics this debate between
sam and malcolm
is really this this uh the undercurrent
for the whole plot how
many roads must have that little subtle
embarrassment that
leslie is playing is great she's always
asking how much do the oppressed
have to do before they can be recognized
as human
beings it's one of those songs that
speaks to
injustice that speaks to hope on those
are timeless
ideals that relate to every generation
this is a white boy
from minnesota who has nothing to gain
from writing a song that speaks more to
the struggles of our people more
to the movement than anything that you
have ever penned in your
life all of them were so present
in this moment and this moment just
breaks my
heart why has this song
gone higher on the pop charts
than anything you got out this was a
difficult scene to shoot because it was
so dialogue heavy and the amount of
emotion that kingsley had to give up
each time just blows me away
good riddance regina is unintrusive
she's let me have full reign in my
sort of crazy process and method there
is no
more room for anyone
not you not me not jimmy not sam
no one to be standing on the fence
anymore
this film works up to this moment and
when it comes it hits you like a freight
train
our people are literally dying in the
streets every day
black people are dying
everyday it's why i love being an actor
i'm getting emotional
we're talking about four of the probably
most
iconic men in american history but for a
lot of people in the world
oh my goodness oh my so pretty
we all kind of looked at them as deities
forgetting to look at them as men first
what originally sparked me to want to
write about this story is that it was a
real night
february 25th 1964 it was really
interesting to think about these
four gentlemen from very different areas
and in this very specific segregated
time
i thought of all four of them as just so
unapologetically black
yes catches marcellus clay is the new
heavyweight
champion of the world the dialogue just
punched me in the gut the things that
were
most important to me that i wanted to
push further
were the vulnerability and strength that
black men have
that the men that i know possess i
wanted the
heart of the film to be about having
these four men have a private discussion
that we get to be privy to
unfortunately there wasn't a lot of
information about what they actually
discussed
i decided what if i took everything i
knew about what happened leading up to
that night and use it to
inform and power the conversation that
these four men would have
you used to be such a fun cat now you
acting in private the way you are on
camera
i think what happened is the occasion
turned into an opportunity
for these four men to get together and
discuss things there were very few
people
living in america who would understand
the life that they were living
who would understand the unique
pressures they were under it's a work of
fiction
but i like to say that it's a work of
fiction powered by fact because the
reality of it is that 1964 was a
crucible year for all four of these men
and they all experienced transformative
change
in the days weeks and months after this
particular night
i thought that this film would work best
if it was a director who was a fresh
voice one of the first people who got to
read the script was regina
after i got the job i said i feel like
this is a love letter to black men
it's so honest it's so raw
it's so quiet it's so loud
everything's not so black and white like
you make it out to be well this is all
to a hopping star
balancing the levity of the subject
matter of the conversations
a lot of that came from just having a
great quartet
of actors where they truly understood
that they were brothers this movement
that we are in
is called a struggle because we are
fighting for our lives
this is a film about respect and love
and we're showing men
who are supporting each other in a way
that is not often celebrated
brothers like sam and you and cassius
you all are our greatest weapons not
anyone's weapons
malcolm you need to be jimmy the debate
that these guys engage in is a debate
that's been going on since long before
them and it's a debate that's still
going on today
how do we progress as a people how do we
bring about change
that's the debate the line has got to be
drawn in the sand jimmy
a line that says either you stand on
this side with us
or you stand over on that side against
us cast and i i believe
i believe in that brother's potential
jimmy too much
too much to let him stay over on the
other side all four of
the men in this film have impacted our
lives in some way even if we didn't know
that our lives were being impacted by
them the goal is for us to
really be free
[Music]
we want the world to speak but we're
safe to be ourselves
[Music]
without having to answer to anybody for
it
we have to be there for each other
brothers who could move mountains
without lifting a finger